Now what is glucose? Glucose is a simple sugar in the blood, and it provides
energy for the cells throughout the body, including the brain. Now, if we go
for a long time without eating, our blood sugar drops, and in turn the
hypothalamus, which monitors glucose levels, will signal the drive to obtain
food. Thinking back to the homeostatic model for motivation, we see this
example of the brain detecting a lack of glucose, and then signaling for us to
obtain food. Some of the hormones that stimulate our appetite are neuropeptide
Y, melanin, and ghrelin. For example, when we are hungry, neuropeptide Y is
released from the hypothalamis. And that in turn causes us to be hungry.
Similarly, ghrelin levels rise when we're hungry and fall when we are full.
Another naturally occurring chemical that can increase our appetite are the
endocannabinoids. This is one reason why marijuana is sometimes used
medicinally, to stimulate appetite, when other medicines make people nauseous
and unable to eat. On the flip side, research has shown that blocking the
receptor sights for the endocannabinoids actually decreases eating and results
in weight loss.